we're backstage here at la Perlas first
ready-to-wear the Perla makes every girl
feel sexy when do you feel sexiest I
mean I think that when you know you know
yourself well and you've lived a life
with lots of ups and downs and you get
to be in your 40s I think you feel
pretty good all the time are you going
to Scout any looks for Valentine's if
you have any fun plans I don't think
it's a girl's job to make the plan right
I could not agree with you more Beyonce
just made her incredible announcement
wearing very sexy lingerie how excited
are you for her that she's gonna be the
Mamas twin very excited babies are
always a good thing babies bring good
luck for GUP where do you get the mom
who has everything didn't expect things
went good good la Perlas creative
director Julia Hart was also on hand she
gushed over having when its support
honestly to me it's all about the women
who wear my clothing she puts and imbues
the clothing with her own creative
spirit and that's what gives me so much
pleasure
you